(classical music)
- I don't think I've
ever written a letter.
- The last time I wrote a letter was
in second grade when we had pen pals.
- The last letter I
wrote was to Santa Claus.
- I'm writing a letter
to my dad's boyfriend.
- To my sister.
- To my grandma.
- Ahem, here we go.
Dear sister,
- This is definitely hard.
- I'm in my head, I can't get out my head.
- I don't remember how to write letters.
What do you say?
Thank God it is over.
I'm never writing a letter again.
- This might be a cute thing that I could
do with my grandma, definitely.
- There's so much that came up for me when
I wrote this letter that I don't
think would have come
up if I was texting him.
Sharing why he means so much to me,
and how much he's changed my life in
the past five years.
That gets emotional.
It's hard to address how you really feel
about somebody and how
much someone means to you,
until you sit down and you
don't have your cellphone,
you don't have any media, there's nothing,
and you're just with the pen and paper.